joining us now without a doubt my
favorite new actor in Hollywood sunny
power he is the eight-year-old who
literally stole everyone's heart
including my own in the movie lion it is
the real-life story of a little boy who
ends up on a train a thousand miles from
home and I just love this kid Sonny
thank you for being here thank you how
did you like the Golden Globes Golden
Globes gets high like a stage beyond
what that ten I got born for that era
lovely fantastic he loved it
Sonny is speaking in his native language
of Hindi his translator ruled that's why
he is here with us also you really have
become close with Dev haven't you is he
like a brother ah yeah what's your
favorite thing about dev in Agua nada we
play a lot and he's just like me he's
like a little child he keeps tossing me
up in the air my favorite part is that I
get to teach him Hindi we're gonna take
you back for a second to your moment on
that Golden Globe stage my dad watch
this movie slang yes mommy nirvana
my mother saw it and I spoke to her and
she was like I'm extremely proud of you
son alright did you have a favorite star
out there like I know Matt Damon was
right in front
Rondon so the thing is that I don't
watch any American movies as I watch WWE
John Cena Undertaker the rock they are
my American heroes the Undertaker in the
rock yeah that's cool Nicole Kidman
plays your adopted mom in the movie what
was it like working with Nicole Ablett
it was a lot of fun working with Nicole
and we played a lot of cricket together
to bond there is one scene in the movie
where you are dying for a dessert to
watch this
there goes our economy levy gonna kill
you like them okay I got a little
surprise for you
jalebi sunny ah you're welcome
let's see hmm oh we're good excellent
mmm sunny you eat those thank you for
coming here we are so happy you came
here and will you do me a favor
will you say to everybody out there
thanks for watching we'll see you
tomorrow thanks for watching thanks for
watching we'll see you tomorrow then
see you tomorrow
[Music]
you